oh yeah that's that god-awful child
actor Jimmy Boyd he did that Christmas
music West child actor of all time right
under our noses and not a single cry to
dispense do you know about this you're
kidding me Donny's are Johnny's Jimmy's
yeah something like that does to a kid
good good I'm not gonna lie just
something out there dude I'm so sorry
mom oh well one's dead and once the
greatest loved yeah and then what
happens watch this something I can kill
no that's the best thing we ever did you
can't do no yo Jimmy boy
we have an entire I'm sorry I'm today
miss Mason tell me what is it you hope
to find to you something I've lost
most of our visitors don't get visitors
and you too two minutes ago and I said I
didn't need you okay
now I've always are rudely interrupted
hey you ready so you can see there's a
lot of ceiling tiles just everywhere
everywhere yes there's a man behind the
camera with a skull cap on years ago -
oh I love go team is a man-child
imagine yes and a button up - it's a
wonderful stain and that silly tail
right there I can smell it I'm not too
sure what it is but
bright lights just shining on us shining
on us like the stars we are I don't know
what stars are stars big beautiful balls
of gas burning billions and billions of
miles away
I think apart yes how well you see if
you watch The Lion King Timon and Pumbaa
they were talking about this hey it's
kind of ironic that he's talking about
gas because he's actually the gassy
character of my movie the irony yes Wow
where the coinsidence
there's a green screen behind us